when Joe Biden refers to the
semi-fascists and the existential
threats to our democracy he is referring
to a much larger group he is referring
to half of the country he is referring
to the Maga Republicans which is to say
statistically the Republicans which is
to say half of the country
which is a strange thing to think that
government of the People by the people
for the people could be threatened by
the very existence of half of the people
that our sacred two-party system faces
the threat of annihilation if anyone
even thinks of voting for the party that
is out of power
that that wouldn't make me think that
something is amiss about our sacred
democracy
I suppose the first thing that would be
amiss about our democracy is that we
don't actually have a democracy The Men
Who Built our country were deeply
distrustful of democracy from the
beginning not just back in 1789 when our
constitution went into effect or even in
1776 when the founding fathers declared
independence from Britain but even
further back in 1630 when Governor
Winthrop described the Massachusetts Bay
Colony as a shining city on a hill and a
model of Christian charity even further
back in 1620 when Governor Bradford and
the pilgrims landed at Plymouth Rock
all of those men and especially the
framers of our constitution
gave us a mixed regime with an executive
power and aristocratic element and of
course strong Democratic representation
in a federal system that balanced power
between three branches of government as
well as between three distinct interests
the people the states and the higher
Unity of the people and the states in a
nation
the nation has a physical aspect
spacious skies amber waves of grain
purple mountain majesties
see the shining sea you know how it goes
the nation in its physical nature has a
body
that is the body politic but our nation
just like the people who constitute it
is not merely a body our nation like all
nations is also a soul
it must be the soul is the substantial
form of the body it is the intellectual
principle of the body
the soul animates the body without the
soul the body is dead a body politic
must have a soul in order to live so
what animates America
for most of American History the answer
was obvious
Christianity
the pilgrims of the Mayflower undertook
their Voyage primarily quote for the
glory of God and advancement of the
Christian faith our Founders and framers
established our nation according to John
Adams only for a moral and religious
people and Adam spelled out precisely
what he meant by religion and morality
in an 1813 letter to Thomas Jefferson
quote
the general principles on which the
fathers achieved Independence were the
only principles in which that beautiful
assembly of young gentlemen could unite
the general principles of Christianity
in which all these sects were United
Adams is clear articulation of the
nation's religious grounding poses a
problem for The secularists Who deny
America's Christian spirit because it
contradicts another quote also
ostensibly from John Adams on which the
argument against America's Christian
character rests according to the
secularists John Adams declared in 1796
that quote the government of the United
States is not in any sense founded on
the Christian religion
so how do we make sense of that apparent
contradiction
here we see the proof of Alexander
Pope's warning that a little learning is
a dangerous thing
because when we look into the origin of
the phrase we find that it does not come
from any founding document
it does not come from the Declaration of
Independence or the Federalist or even
the private papers of The Men Who Built
the country
the statement comes instead from the
Treaty of Tripoli which although signed
by Adams was not written by him it was
written by Diplomat and Jeffersonian
Republican Joel Barlow and it was only
written to persuade Muslim Pirates to
stop abducting and enslaving American
sailors
the statement was not so much a
statement of principle
or even of law as it was a ransom
payment by a struggling early Nation to
International criminals
when they were not attempting to placate
Muslim Pirates our founding fathers
spoke much more favorably of
Christianity and its role in public life
Adams obviously directly contradicted
his own professed nonsense from the
Treaty of Tripoli and most if not all of
the other Founders did as well John Jay
co-author of the Federalist and the
first Chief Justice of the United States
put it bluntly quote Providence is given
to our people the choice of their rulers
and it is the duty as well as the
privilege and interest of our Christian
Nation to select and prefer Christians
for their rulers
had the ACLU existed at the time of the
founding it would have taken the Chief
Justice to court there is no question
about it
in 1814 Francis Scott Key composed his
most famous poem the defense of Fort
McHenry
in which he summed up the American creed
oh thus be it ever when free men shall
stand between their loved home and the
war's desolation blessed with Victory
and peace May the heaven-rescued land
praise the power that hath made and
preserved us a nation then conquer we
must when our cause it is just and this
be our motto in God is our trust and the
Star-Spangled Banner in Triumph shall
wave or the land of the free in the home
of the brave
the U.S Navy recognized Key's poem for
official use in 1889. the White House
followed suit in 1916 and it became the
national anthem by Congressional
resolution in 1931.
with the affirmation of then-president
Herbert Hoover
in 1954 President Eisenhower added a
variation of this near Century and a
half long national motto to the Pledge
of Allegiance and as anyone with a
dollar in his pocket knows the motto
also appears on all U.S currency an
important reminder especially these days
that it is a much safer bet to trust in
God than in the value of the US dollar
I could go on sighting the countless
other evidences of America's Christian
character but there is not enough time
in this entire conference let alone in
this speech suffice it to say the soul
of America is and always has been
essentially Christian
and since the Revolutionary War America
is and has been a nation
so what does that make America's
traditional political order
I'm no academic I don't have an advanced
degree in political science but it seems
to me that if a political Community is
defined at the physical level as a
nation and not say an Empire or a
city-state and then it is defined at the
metaphysical level as Christian and not
say
zoroastrian I don't know
then that would mean that the
traditional political order of the
United States is Christian nationalism
hmm
I failed to see how even the most
zealous opponent of Christian
nationalism could look at any Epoch in
the history of the United States and
come to any other conclusion
and yet today
the liberal establishment considers
Christian nationalism to be the most
dangerous and radical idea in public
life how is that
simple
the liberal establishment detests the
traditional American Nation both in Body
and Soul at the level of the body the
Liberals seek to disfigure the nation
most notably over the past 60 some odd
years by erasing National borders and
flooding the country with millions of
foreign Nationals each year the largest
migration of human beings in recorded
history by the way and at the level of
the soul the Liberals seek to corrupt
the nation perverting and in fact
inverting the nation's animating Spirit
its moral and religious order
until 1963 Public Schools taught the
Bible and banned pornography
since 1963 public schools ban banned the
Bible and increasingly teach pornography
if you have not come across the
children's book genderqueer which is a
pornographic comic book by someone named
Maya kababi consider yourself lucky
unfortunately your children are not so
lucky very likely many of them have come
across that book in their high school
and middle school libraries
much as we might wish to dismiss this
whole debate with some platitude about
Free Speech the question cannot be
avoided because the schools have to
teach something
if the schools teach biblical morality
then they can't teach genderqueer
morality
if the schools teach genderqueer
morality they can't teach biblical
morality this inversion in the latter
half of the 20th century was not a
development or evolution of our national
character
nor was it a neutral expansion of free
speech
it was a spiritual Revolution a change
in religion a reordering of the nation's
soul
you can actually track this change as it
occurred year by year yorum first called
my attention to this strange fact with a
simple Google engram search an engram
search which demonstrates the prevalence
of words and phrases in books over time
the phrase Christian Nation according to
Google's textual analysis appears in
English literature consistently from the
16th century onward peaking in the
middle of the 19th century same goes for
Christian country same goes for
Christian civilization which really took
off in the 19th century peaked around
1870 and has been declining ever since
as one might expect
where it gets a little bit strange is
when you look up the literary history of
the phrase liberal democracy which today
we are told describes the very essence
of our nation it is simply taken as a
given that America is at her core a
liberal democracy
but the phrase liberal democracy appears
pretty much nowhere according to
Google's textual analysis until 1930
it didn't really start to take off until
the mid-1950s it actually only really
spiked around 1982.
so if liberal democracy constitutes the
soul of our society no one seemed to
know it until about 40 years ago
the phrase liberal democracy appears
nowhere in the text of the Constitution
or The Federalist Papers or the
Declaration of Independence
the word liberal appears in the
Federalist just five times and then only
in the classical sense meaning generous
it doesn't refer to any particular
political philosophy
indeed the word democracy and its
derivations appear nowhere in the
Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence it appears just 18 times in
the Federalist each time it appears it
is invoked with disapproval
so how on Earth did America become a
liberal democracy
the word Nation
along with its derivatives by contrast
appears in all three founding documents
it appears in the Federalist alone
569 times always with approval
the Federalist proposes that America
quote should to all general purposes be
one nation under one federal government
America's body politic according to the
founding fathers would be National her
sole Christian
one might call it Christian nationalism
liberals hate Christian nationalism not
because it is a departure from the
American political tradition but because
it is the American political tradition
which the liberals do not like
liberals hate Christian nationalism
because it is the opposite of atheist
globalism which is the scheme that they
prefer the term liberal democracy lends
itself to this agenda of atheist
globalism by diverting the nation's
attention away at the physical level
from its own citizens in favor of the
ever-expanding International Community
of supposed democracies and by turning
the nation's Soul away at the
metaphysical level from our common good
which can only come from God toward the
glittering Idol of individualism and
choice
the left has led this spiritual and
physical mutilation of our country there
is no question about it
I think of it as a sort of gender
reassignment surgery for the nation one
that has turned a once beautiful
creature in the image and likeness of
God into a grotesque caricature
fashioned after our own fantasies and
delusions
the leftists led the transformation
but to be fair
they didn't meet very much resistance
they managed to do it pretty quickly
they couldn't they couldn't have done it
if the conservatives had pushed back in
a serious way such a radical
restructuring of the nation's body and
spirit could never have taken place in
so short a period of time had the
conservatives had even a smidge of the
clarity and courage necessary to
conserve anything at all
the conservatives have failed to
conserve the nation and continue to fail
each day because they fall into the Trap
laid by the Liberals and fail to
recognize the importance of both the
nation's Body and Soul as well as the
connection between them
consider how conservatives have
attempted in vain to stop the spread of
transgenderism
the Liberals argue that there is a
difference between biological sex
and gender expression
it's a little more complicated than that
because they also refer to the
biologically female phallus and the
biologically male uterus and things but
we can put that aside for now at their
most coherent the transgender argument
rests on this distinction between sex
and gender
how do conservatives argue against it to
date we simply claim that there is no
such distinction there is no such thing
as gender expression
we cite facts about genitals and
chromosomes and we appeal to the same
sort of reductive Soul denying scientism
that the Liberals use to get us into
this mess in the first place
but of course there is such a thing as
gender expression
of course men can be effeminate and
women can be masculine of course the
behaviors and self-conceptions of men
and women can differ from those implied
by their bodies of course living bodies
have souls which lack chromosomes and
genitals but nevertheless are real
the reason transgenderism is wrong is
not that there is no distinction between
the physical and metaphysical self the
symbol and the symbolized the body and
the soul
the reason the transgenderism is wrong
is that men are not supposed to act like
women
transgenderism is wrong because there
very much is a distinction between our
sex and the way in which we express our
sex and we have a duty to express our
sex in the correct way we have a duty to
bring the symbol and the symbolized much
closer together Duty was once a common
concept among conservatives in many ways
it defined conservative thought
Edmund Burke as he laments the passing
of the age of chivalry for that of
sophisters economists and calculators
eulogizes quote that generous loyalty to
rank and sex that proud submission that
dignified obedience that subordination
of the heart which kept alive even in
servitude itself the spirit of an
exalted freedom
such Notions are considered ridiculous
today not only to the left but also in
many quarters of the right
the right which has forsaken Duty
sacrifice obedience and submission in
favor of the same Babel about rights and
entitlement for which we once rightly
mocked the left
at other times when conservatives are
not denying the soul in a misguided
effort to own the libs we fall into the
opposite error and deny the body we see
this especially in the case of
immigration
for decades self-styled conservatives
have denied the physical aspect of the
nation entirely parroting the same
liberal platitude that America is
nothing but an idea
not a place not a people just an idea
even the most hard-line mainstream
conservatives on the issue of
immigration have denied that there would
be any reason to curtail the
unrestricted flow of foreigners into the
United States insisting instead quite to
the contrary that America should embrace
more and more immigration just so long
as its legal immigration
but a nation that does not have any
practical borders a nation that does not
in any way distinguish its own people
from any other people is not a nation at
all
a living Nation must have an idea to
animate it it must have a soul but it
must also have a body without which the
soul cannot act in time and space
the central thesis of Joe Biden's
presidency articulated in the earliest
days of his campaign and reiterated just
last week is that we are now engaged in
a battle for the soul of our nation
I don't know if you've looked at some of
his appointees recently
I think the thesis is correct
uh Joe Biden's assistant Health
secretary is a man who thinks that he is
a woman and who demands that we cast
straight little kids Joe Biden's Deputy
assistant Energy Secretary is a
psychosexual sadist who dresses grown
men up in leather dog outfits and
photographs himself dragging them around
on a leash and Joe Biden's new Deputy
monkey pox coordinator is a store brand
Anton LaVey whose headshot depicts him
wearing a leather pentagram chest
harness on top of his other pentagram
pectoral tattoo
now in Joe Biden's defense
he never told us which side of the
battle he is on
so we may be in a battle for the soul of
a Nation but if Personnel is policy
our soul is in trouble
if that bizarre speech that Biden made a
couple of weeks ago
you know the angry one with this sort of
infernal red Lighting in the dark with
the gesticulating and the yelling if
that speech was any indication the
president wants to take the soul of our
nation straight down to the bad place
Ronald Reagan rightly understood that
ultimately there is no such thing as
left or right that when you really get
down to it there is only an up or down
and in time and space we must always be
moving in One Direction or the other
there can be no stasis there can be no
neutrality political communities must
have a shape and a shared end
vibrant political communities the
various parts of the body politic
fulfill the function and Duty proper to
their role and all of the parts work
together toward the common good or the
body politic will atrophy and die
the left is mounting a concerted effort
an attack on our nation's Body and Soul
the leftists wish for our traditional
Nation to die
they say so
it remains to be seen whether
conservatives will muster the wisdom to
understand this and the will to live we
have before us a choice between life and
death blessing and cursing if we are to
have any political future at all we
conservatives at least must choose life
life in body and in Soul that the United
States and our descendants may live